hello welcome to this video playing a
van in / that's Christian toika from
Germany one of the players that I don't
really have a good score against I'm not
quite sure why that is but I tend to
have problems against him if we okay
doesn't mind to play that reverse benoni
it's not great for white but you can of
course play it yeah we had this a couple
of times and he plays d4 and then we let
me play this position that that should
be about eagle trying for we should have
six trading trading stuff that good
bishop there isn't going there yeah
maybe okay now i have six less nine to
five so i go age 60 biggest danger and
this kind of position is to to kind of
ya lose lots of time while trying to
look for something special and then
somehow get into a time pressure and the
pragmatic thing is just to trade of
everything and play this position which
is well it's okay for me really so I
mean I rather blacker than white
now that's equal so a for group takes
rook takes Bishop takes my ass probably
still equal even even with my more
active oh I'm with my more active King
before he might have looked before I
awesome
I can it still okay it's equal what can
you do and so should be five maybe takes
takes King into that could be good right
a bit dicey to play it so quickly but it
seems right if you take something that
must be a good end game i get c 5 and so
on it should be winning actually and
here i can go for King e5 king d 4 okay
thought King it too
nowhere that's an awful endgame can try
to increase my strategic advantage here
a little bit with f5 he can barely move
and c5 is lost anyway yeah i can go G
for him or is that a bad idea g4
reckoned with i can do that now take c5
next and now take everything and takes
you five should win but i can also take
this first takes takes takes King see
five heads its checks and then this
winning end game check kinky for you
check check check
white resides yeah not very exciting but
it's it's it's difficult yeah this is
line is very very boring and turn it's
nots not much that I can do about it
that is three line I mean it says it's
boring that he was the displaying here
you can know I cannot really get much
more than what we what we headed the
game where this is a scenario that we
get some kind of end games rather likely
he can play more viciously of course but
he never never tried so we got all
saturated and here he have already happy
with my position as the crew inside
structure famous me a little bit him put
my bishop it's got all those pawns
online squares and I could have played a
4 immediately that was interesting
preventing c5 in the first place get
here for group before is better I didn't
do that route 87 was my idea beat eggs
and then go go over here try to combine
pressure against both pawns it's M is
equal but I thought you should do that
yeah and the snow oh wyd wins with the
capture I didn't did I miss count there
takes takes King e2
honest I forgot about that for ah oh
that's bad it's got air flow of course I
know 85 with the breakthrough ideas wow
so Bishop t5 was a real Pat's a move hmm
I forgot about the breakthrough ideas
yeah it's that's really awful Bishop t5
the only positive thing about the movies
that if he does not play Bishop takes d5
which is the winning move in any other
move like this is rubbish and he's
losing which is what happened here here
black black wins and not very not in a
very difficult a jab remarkable I don't
know what I was thinking there can also
go here your choice just this also wins
and he gets to deform I don't know just
i just thought i miscounted or what I
don't know thought that mocking would be
more active then well it was a very
lucky with who thanks for watching